destiny rise of iron our reviews up I
did a review in progress on release day
after you had done a 10 hour livestream
I played a less of it that morning but
then you know got up my initial opinions
which I think we aligned more initially
yeah and then the farther into what we
got the more our opinions diverged uh
yeah I mean I think it's just our I mean
I think we both felt the same way
everything leading up to the rate I
didn't dispute the kind of the score
that you were like hovering around at
that time which is ultimately the score
you gave it and it will and I could see
that like this log or the grind of you
know you after you get through most of
the story which was good again but short
and after that it's kind of like this
slow process of slowly leveling in the
hopes that you can then get to the raid
and when you get to the raid which is
you know something you did and I did I
thought it was a pretty great rate
there's probably like one boss that I
didn't care too much for but it's all a
perspective of like how much does that
rate impact you write like is that
enough to elevate it to a seven yeah not
and that's kind of where I think our
paths kinda forked in the road so to
speak what uh without spoiling too much
what do you think of like the raid
bosses and that the mechanics of the
raid sure I thought it was fun I mean it
was I don't know if it's just because me
and my some of the guys that i read with
normally just haven't rated in a while
but uh the genuine the genuine
excitement of kind of going into it
together for the most part blind i did
look up some shots and stuff like that
but like actually doing some of those
things like the rain mechanics and why
not it was like pretty refreshing pretty
fun it was some of it is tied into like
what you did before the raid like the
strikes and stuff like that but not all
of it like some of those mechanics lends
itself into the raid but I thought the
raid was a lot of fun I think the
mechanics are fun I think visually some
of the set pieces in there are just like
stunning I'm just like wow it's like
blow me away like and I don't want to
get too spoilery with it but there are
some some areas like within and outside
of inside and outside other
rate that are like pretty crazy I wish
there was a strike in this expansion
that kind of used the same assets
anesthetic and kind of general idea of
this raid because the closer they got
was uh what is the anarchy heist think
I'm screwing that up with the ogre and
the art archpriest so again tomorrow the
other one yeah new one when I got a
reskin yea which was a good strike in my
opinion I like that boss if I just
something like spectacular but it's yeah
like the ogres attacking you you you
realize pretty quickly ease immune the
entire fight so then you have to kill
the archpriest while this ogre is
charging you I like that boss if I like
the mechanic that the damn dynamic
between those two and the level design
for that one was pretty like different
than most other strikes because it had
you going and going up and down and left
and right but yeah I would have been
kind of cool to see some of the more
raid kind of like style in like a strike
or something something that may be in
the previous expansions I feel like they
kind of like led you towards the raid in
a way I credit for it yeah it's kind of
like oh like there's you know just like
one of the bosses you might fight he
runs away you know and you kind of have
to go chase him down and for with the
was service for you know you have to
move the orb while he's like rotating
this wall it's all about placement kind
of which rays are often about like
platforming and kind of being the right
spot at the right time and like actually
not getting wiped in one hit but there
was one of the earlier boss again
without spoiling too much earlier boss
in the raid that kind of you're not just
fighting it you're also kind of using it
as like transportation almost the I mean
it's not go out to call that Zamboni the
deaths and that's the name of the boss
okay I like this game it's uh yeah if
you should've given in 27 here's Wayne
that's your Wayne Gretzky with a giant
battle axe going at the Zamboni don't
clean my rink no there's definitely none
of that no um but yeah what do you think
of the strikes because i like i said i
like the actual new strike but you know
septics perfected the one we see right
here is epics prime but you know just
like what now he just splicer see
vitamins are trying to use siva we talk
more about like siva being that nanobot
playing that the Lords of iron back in
the day with Lord Saladin who you'll see
if you ever didn't like iron banner crew
Sevilla crucible events this all doesn't
make sense it's just like pvp stuff that
happens on a weekly basis or whatever
like a scheduled basis they go to the
back story with that we can talk about
the actual storyline campaign later but
you know
he was this nanobot play get plays into
some of the strikes and it changes the
enemy is kind of like how the taken
enemies perform differently I didn't
feel like the splicer enemies were that
much different this time around they
were just you know buffed in terms of
damage and defense yeah I mean I sir
would use for that for the most part on
that in the in that regard that the
taken when they had done the taken felt
like there was more stuff happening with
that then there is what the splicers so
and and to talk about the strikes to it
does kind of suck a little bit that they
were just kind of some rehashes I mean
it's kind of hard regardless but I mean
I still enjoyed the this epics like
encounter that last encounter even
though it's kind of similar to what it
was before but some of the mechanics at
least we're kind of cool it's like you
know you get a scorch Canada then take a
shield off it's like something that you
would see in like a MMO you know what I
mean and the music during that like
fight is just like amazing I don't think
enough people talk about how amazing the
music is even though that's just one
small part of the game but like that
song that that song is kind of the same
as it was before but like more like kind
of metal and whatnot it's just like
awesome but yeah yeah the the enemies
didn't feel that much different this
time around even the plaguelands the new
patrol zone it there was more to do and
it was a different area but it was still
very much just like Earth from destiny
or one and two if yeah I mean there's
like I was seeing anything new like the
dread-nots I loved and taken King it was
very much dislike infested kind of
foreign like just derelict vessel in the
middle of Saturn's rings that you were
going into and there's like new public
events that's when they introduced the
court of or except and then there's you
know our conf origin this one which is
kind of like a reworked Court of Oryx in
a way like nine player max 90 their
public event I didn't feel like the
plague lines were offering that much new
like for me to explore I was exploring
them mostly for that quest line we're
actually trying to complete all the
missions for Shiro the hunter would you
think of like the new era yeah I think
part of the reason why the plague Lance
why doesn't seem as cool when you go
through it as just like an area is
probably because you're going through a
lot of that through the story I I would
imagine so you kind of go oh I kind of
been here before whereas it wasn't
always the case with like the other
expansions and whatnot so
I could see why that felt that way and
there is only one kind of like new
patrol mission which is a fun one
because you get to use the axe but I
mean like other than that you're just
kind of like killing stuff and Archon
Forge is an interesting concept well not
really I guess because it's a tree it's
it that's that's my it's because I with
most of this expansion is because it's
like a watered down version of like
corte works they wanted something like
faster paced that like it resembled more
of like a horde mode not something that
you had to be super strategic about yeah
it was more of like a lot of stuffs
coming at you like frantically you have
a timer five minutes you have to kill
stuff fast and that's kind of the
concept of that but I think because it
went from like you do in court of Orcs
where there were mechanics of like oh if
you don't bring the two nights together
you can't damage them or there's three
Wizards if you don't kill them all
within a timely manner they start to
respawn so like they're those probably
seemed more interesting than just
killing a bunch of stuff but i don't
know maybe some people like the horde
style mode so maybe that's why they went
with it our Archon sport is kind of like
an A and they didn't really do
themselves a big favor because you can't
stack those offerings so people can't
really change them if you don't have
them or like if the group doesn't have
them where's like in court like you know
you could be there with three people and
you can just keep doing it and keep
doing activities but for whatever reason
they kind of like gated you from like
doing them like over and over we were
talking about it earlier with a division
but with the update 1.4 it's apparently
gonna like revamp how you level up a
little bit with like at least from my
experience someone who kind of had to
catch up right before I came out with my
light level it felt very much more like
a very very gradual quick very grinding
now with like okay should I should equip
all my even if I don't like guns when
equip my things to get my highest light
so next thing that drops well you know
ideally be higher light left my light
level and it was just like constantly
playing that getting in strike playlist
and going through the same you know a
few strikes obviously you know which
strikes work best and what would like
drop the class specific items and
whatnot but it felt I know that does the
grind is part of destiny I do enjoy
initially but after a while this was
just too much almost yeah this this one
was definitely a big grind
than the ones in the past but it kind of
it's kind of part of it is because they
came out that April update which was
like the infusing of light kind of stuff
which a lot of people were happy about
right and I think they wanted to carry
that forward so you can still use the
old items that you like and bring them
up to current light level but I think in
doing that because you know you still
have to get to like raid level they
probably had to find a mechanic to like
buffer you from getting there too fast
because if you get there too fast then
like what do you have left to play right
like that's the thing with destiny is
that yeah you have your chores and stuff
like that but if you get to end game
right away like in a week which some
people have you're not there's not much
left to do outside of the stuff in the
book which again is still gated like you
still can't finish that stuff almost
like you do it so it's like kind of like
extending the life of it but at the cost
of kind of making players like Ryan
through that stuff like it's kind of an
unfortunate circumstance where like it's
already hard enough to get a raid group
right because that mechanics not
necessarily in the game yet but they
have community sites and lfg stuff on
their site to help facilitate that but
like to get to the light level to do
that which even was like a little bit of
a struggle for you at first because you
know that is a slog a little bit even
though you are getting rewards it's just
minimal like it feels minimal you know
and it so it takes time like that is
kind of shitty to me like I want more
people to be able to do the raid but
then it's like how do you find the
balance like as a raid person I feel
like an elitist and it's weird for me
that goob like oops you ride who is a
gamespot fan is like almost as high
light level as me and has like he's done
like only two parts of the right you
know what I mean where's in the past it
was like oh you get to the point where
you're stuck you have to raid and then
you're either hired because of the rate
so then like where's the balance there
right like do you try to kick is
becoming more of a casual game I feel I
mean even if they kept it as extended as
it is or it it sounds like if the
strikes are more original and like
especially the the bosses that you were
fighting like that that sort of could
have provided that balance that you're
talking about where it's like okay I'll
take a longer raid if that's what it
takes to keep me playing if initially I
was given things that were super
interesting but it sounded like you had
to go through stuff that was recycled
content to get to something that was
just stretched out needlessly yeah well
even in the strike playlist you'll be
playing to like grind through the strike
close keep your stripe on it she'll be
playing strikes from your one and two
because they're put into oh gotcha yeah
well the nightfall this week wasn't the
new strike right the next week yeah with
the new strike but then this week it was
like winter winters run but then they've
changed it again to saber now but yeah
so yeah in general you're it's not just
like that expansions content is roots
Reese candles contest you're playing or
content as well in order to like you
know like society successfully Brian
yeah the grind is real and then in terms
of campaign it's kind of the same thing
as taking king it serves mainly to set
up a late-game quest lines or the exotic
quest lines of the new quest givers a
new area of new social area the new
patrol area which is the plague lands in
this case fell winter peak was kind of
cool it was just like aesthetically it's
like Game of Thrones kind of mixed with
lord of the rings that high fantasy
stuff the intro cinematic was gorgeous
but it was one cinematic and then you
beat the campaign in 90 minutes you get
the blade at the end the exotic item
it's not really spoiler I think most
people know that by this point but it
wasn't there wasn't much context to the
missions aside from what the quest giver
told you at first again like I didn't
get into this just to play the campaign
but the campaign like you know during
marketing everything before it looked
pretty badass and then I played it was
kind of like lackadaisical I didn't I
don't remember much of it I like the
love the gallon horn quest line that
last mission with gala horn was great
felt kind of like something out of
bungees halo days like the scale of it
and there's a few I didn't get kvass
stock the original rifle you get in
destiny but the exotic quest lines as
always we're pretty entertaining despite
the fact that some of the quests in
those lines were just like fetch quest
patrol missions yeah but that's like
part of that's just how that kind of
like how quests work if I mean I never
want to call destiny and MMO but like
those patrol missions those kind of
quest line kind of stuff like picking up
medallions that are all over like the
play lens that's a very like MMO thing
to do yeah it's not really worth giving
it a pass though I think the fair
criticism to say it's like yeah its
traditional and that's kind of border
but but it up but I guess I have a
different perspective on it is because
it's like yeah I wasn't that thrilled
about having to pick that stuff up but
it's kind of like the you can see the
light at the end of the tunnel and like
it makes it i I don't know if it
necessarily makes it more rewarding to
know that I did all that to get the
Geller horn but you know that you earned
it right and like you know that someone
has a gala horn went through that same
thing but yeah and then the kibosh often
was cool like there's like this
heartfelt moment that if you've been
playing destiny since like year one like
there's a nice little like slight little
nugget of story like intimacy between
you and the ghost and just like kind of
like looking back at like you know the
two years that you've been playing
destiny and like hey you know but yeah
groups you Ryan the chat said hey wait I
got to access phase to check your facts
Eric hey yeah alright so that's rise of
iron yeah the reviews up on gamespot
gave it a six out of ten it's I think
it's worth playing if you want to grind
and you want to get the new gear
obviously if your arc or does any fan
the raid is well worth it or the rate is
well worth playing the raid if it's
worth the grind it's up to you but yeah
that is destiny um rise of iron it's out
on ps4 xbox one right now